[Musique]
l'espace territoire sans fin que l'homme
tente de conquérir depuis plus de 50 ans
l'espace 7 l'exploration de l'extérieur
aller plus loin et puis c'est aussi
penser des choses qui sont utiles à la
terre 4 octobre 1957 Spoutnik premier
satellite en orbite 12 avril 1961 yuri
Gagarine premier homme dans l'espace
21 juillet 1969 Neil Armstrong premier
terrien à avoir foulé un sol
extraterrestre la lune
et alors que les deux grandes puissances
de la guerre froide se livrent à une
course à l'espace la France va venir
modifier cet équilibre elle met en
orbite son propre Spoutnik le satellite
Astérix le 26 novembre 1965 la France
devient ainsi la troisième puissance
spatiale mondiale
la France a su se démarquer et là où
personne ne l'attendait devenant ainsi
un véritable trait d'union entre les
blocs de l'est et de l'ouest permettant
à la compétition de laisser peu à peu la
place à la coopération on a encore
beaucoup de choses à explorer à
découvrir ce n'est vraiment que le début
[Musique]
la France et l'espace
ce sont des hommes des astronautes qui
ont touché du doigt ce nouveau continent
infini comme s'il voulait justifier de
l'importance d'une présence physique
dans ce nouveau territoire
la noblesse du métier d'astronaute à
cette époque c'était qu'on était jamais
sûr d'aller dans l'espace on était
jamais sûr de partir 9 français ont déjà
approché le cosmos le dixième est en
chemin posez une pièce sur une autre
planète quelque part où personne n'a
jamais mis c'est mon rêve à moi
et demain les vols suborbitaux feront de
chacun de nous des possibles touristes
de l'espace
[Musique]
la conquête spatiale française c'est
aussi des satellites qui rendent
l'espace utile
il permet de surveiller la terre les
océans de rapprocher les hommes entre
eux de les guider de les protéger une
journée sans satellite et le monde
contemporain serait en chaos
l'espace en France c'est également de
grandes missions d'exploration des
planètes du soleil des comètes regardez
ailleurs toujours plus loin pour
comprendre d'où l'on vient
et pour bien comprendre comment la
France est imposée en 50 années de
conquêtes spatiales il faut revenir sur
l'histoire de ces fusées
des fusées sondes au lanceur de
satellites elles ont révolutionné la
position de la France dans le monde
comment à force de persévérance les
défis techniques ont été relevés par
l'ingéniosité de quelques-uns
quand on lance une fusée et qu'on sait
qu'on est les premiers à envoyer dans
l'espace des instruments que personne
n'a construit auparavant on sait qu'on
va découvrir quelque chose de nouveau
Véronique diamant Ariane
décollage pour l'univers passionnant de
ses fusées qui ont fait de la France la
troisième puissance spatiale
[Musique]
5 4 3 2 unités feu
l'aventure spatiale française commence
avec le programme des fusées Véronique
[Musique]
au sortir de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
les militaires créent secrètement dans
un laboratoire du ministère de la
Défense à Vernon dans l'Eure les
premiers missiles et les premières
fusées françaises
il s'appuie pour cela sur une
technologie révolutionnaire pour
l'époque développé par les Allemands
pendant la guerre les fusées A4 plus
sinistrement connu sous le nom de V2
le puit et la fin de la guerre il y
avait le souci des galets sur les
Allemands avaient fait dans dans le
développement de missiles
Jacques Blamont est l'un des pionniers
de l'espace en France depuis ses débuts
sur les fusées sont de Véronique il
contribue toujours à la compétence
française dans la recherche spatiale
attention les V2 étaient un le V2 est un
engin très compliqué la véronique était
un engin très simple
le V2 réalisé sous la direction
technique de l'ingénieur vers norfon
Brown et la première fusée moderne à
propulsion liquide et surtout la
première arme de destruction longue
distance elle pouvait emmener une tonne
de poudre dans un rayon de 300 km
Paris mais surtout Londres et en verre
en connaîtront les foudres
sur décision du général de Gaulle qui
n'entend pas rester sans arme de défense
de ce nouveau type propre à la France
des savants allemands qui avaient mis au
point le V2 sont récupérés
une centaine d'entre eux sont installés
dès 1947 à Vernon ils vont d'ailleurs
former le cœur des équipes de
développement des premiers engins
français le programme Véronique et sur
le point de naître quand on parle du
programme Véronique vous aviez des
ingénieurs français qui travaillaient en
collaboration bien sûr d'où le fait
qu'on puisse parfois surnommer Véronique
lallemande oui effectivement là il y a
un apport allemand conséquent philippe
barnauto est un historien passionné par
l'astronautique française des fusées
sont de Véronique aux premières Ariane
aucun détail n'échappe à sa mémoire
donc on est sur un engin qui est très
modeste un engin qui n'a absolument pas
la même envergure que le V2 en termes de
guidage pas de guidage sur Véronique
Véronique et camoteur le V2 vous aviez
un turbo pompe il y a pas de turbo pont
sur Véronique donc on est vraiment sur
quelque chose de très très rudimentaire
la propulsion le guidage des techniques
qui vont motiver l'armée à mettre au
point une fusée sonde elle sera appelée
Véronique pour Vernon électronique et ne
délivrera pas plus de 4 tonnes de
poussée la roquette science la science
des fusées en particulier des moteurs
fusées c'est la plus difficile à
maîtriser et je pense que pour toute
nation qui démarre quand elle voit tous
les échecs qu'on connu les autres
puissances spatiales avant elle faut
vraiment avoir du culot pour se lancer
là-dedans
[Musique]
véronique est une jeune fille fort
charmante toute jeune encore d'ailleurs
mais qui pèse déjà un bon poids 1500 kg
quelle longueur 6 m 7 m à peu près 7 m
et c'est avec ça que les militaires
l'armée de terre disent éventuellement
aux scientifiques si vous voulez nous
avons là quelque chose qui pourrait être
utile pour aller explorer la haute
atmosphère mais il y a quasiment très
peu de scientifiques qui sont intéressés
à l'époque c'est un sujet encore assez
tabou le V2 le Véronique ce que vous
voulez c'est à ce moment-là considérer
comme une arme c'est une arme de guerre
des essais seront tout de même réalisés
dans l'objectif de maîtriser cette
technologie il se feront en Algérie
la France qui dispose à cette époque
d'un empire colonial encore très étendu
décide pour des raisons logistiques
d'installer ces champs de tir de
missiles et de fusées sondes au cœur du
Sahara
et c'est en 1952 à amagir qui a lieu le
premier lancement réussi d'une Véronique
il s'agit d'une Véronique n pour normale
le 22 mai et l’embarque une charge de 50
kg à une altitude de 70 km
deux ans plus tard c'est une Véronique
na pour normale allongée une version
avec un plus grand réservoir qui réalise
la première expérience scientifique
spatiale consacrée à mesurer
l'absorption des ondes par l'atmosphère
c'est un succès le problème c'est que la
technologie est sommaire il n'y a pas de
télé mesure il faudra prêtre 6 mois pour
récupérer la capsule et les informations
donc ça dissuade
et la dissuasion va dans un premier
temps l'emporter sur le succès la classe
scientifique va continuer de bouder
Véronique le programme des fusées sont
des suspendus jusqu'à l'organisation
d'un événement majeur l'Année
géophysique internationale
récemment l'idée d'une année
internationale géophysique a été lancé
par plus de 60 nations effort
scientifique à l'échelon mondial en vue
de faire progresser notre découverte du
monde planétaire et de l'infini
ces hommes de sciences et leur
gouvernement respectifs décidèrent de se
livrer pendant la durée de l'Année
géophysique internationale à de
nouvelles recherches scientifiques pour
le bénéfice de la communauté mondiale
[Musique]
ça c'est un contexte qui a joué un rôle
important avec comme objectif de de
faire une étude globale de la terre et
nouveauté de faire une étude à la
verticale donc d'explorer toute la haute
atmosphère la banlieue terrestre c'était
un grand projet
et cette à l'occasion de cet événement
scientifique mondial que la course à
l'espace a réellement commencé
à la surprise générale les Soviétiques
devancent les Américains le 4 octobre
1957 le célèbre bip bip du satellite
Spoutnik résonne dans le monde entier
la France avec un peu de retard va elle
aussi participer à cette année
géophysique elle souhaite en effet
accéder à la haute atmosphère pour
réaliser ses propres expériences
le programme véronique est alors
ressuscité avec dès le début la
contestation de la classe scientifique
qui craint que le budget engagé pour le
développement des fusées en pièces
fortement sur celui des expériences une
Véronique améliorée est mise au point
plus fiable plus puissante ce sera la
véronique dite agi pour année
géophysique internationale toute une
série de ces fusées et développées pour
être opérationnel dans les premiers mois
de 1959
on s'est trouvé avec donc un programme
français spatial qui comportait 15
fusées Véronique c'est-à-dire des fusées
sondes qui devaient monter à 200 km en
portant une centaine de kilos qui
n'avait encore jamais été tiré et qui
pourtant ne portait rien on savait pas
quoi faire
si la France se démène pour mettre au
point ses fusées sont de Véronique elle
ne maîtrise pourtant pas encore à
l'époque les instruments qui permettent
de réceptionner depuis le sol les
mesures effectuées en vol par les outils
embarqués ce qu'on appelle la télé
mesure
cette lacune limite donc les
possibilités d'expériences scientifiques
à placer dans les véroniques aggi il
faut alors trouver une solution pour
faire taire les contestataires
et c'est le jeune chercheur Jacques
Blamont qui va suggérer une idée très
simple il recommande d'utiliser les
fusées en s'inspirant d'expérience
américaine il va proposer de disperser
du sodium dans la haute atmosphère pour
en observer et mesurer le comportement
une expérience originale qui ne
nécessite pas de télémesure
je prétendais et ça effectivement été
réalisé que on pouvait mesurer un
paramètre très important et pourtant
inconnu la température de l'atmosphère
dans la tête de la fusée les savants ont
installé leurs appareils de mesure et
une charge de sodium qui sera éjectée
dans la haute atmosphère un des
arguments que j'avais donné pour
l'emploi des nuages de sodium c'est que
ça se verrait ça se voyait à 1000 km les
trois premiers tirs de Véronique agei
réalisé en mars 1959 seront consacrés à
cette expérience
ils vont permettre à Jacques Blamont de
faire une découverte scientifique
sensationnelle qui va ouvrir la voie des
expériences scientifiques françaises
dans la haute atmosphère Jacques Blamont
découvre une limite de l'atmosphère qui
sera appelée turbo pose
c'est bien simple vous avez un nuage de
sodium c'est-à-dire une traînée qui suit
la trajectoire de la fusée ça commence à
marcher quand il y a plus beaucoup
d'oxygène donc au dessus de 100 km alors
cette traînée elle se trouve dans le
milieu où il y a des vents les vents la
poussent et donc on voit cette traînée
se déformer très fortement alors de ces
déformations déduisez l'existence d'une
série de mouvements dans la haute
atmosphère qui apparaissent à partir de
la stratosphère et qui sont très
importants donc vous décrivez la
physique la dynamique de retraite
atmosphère de cette manière-là qui était
inconnue mais en plus il se trouve que
quand vous voyez les photos du nuage de
sodium et bien vous voyez que au-dessus
de 100 km le nuage est très lisse
au-dessous de 100 km aussi bien la
montée qu'à la descente il est globuleux
il met en évidence que les structures de
l'atmosphère le comportement des vents
est différent ça fera la une de la
presse
que ce nom il y a une fierté française
toute la presse de gauche de droite
unanimité sur ce que la France fait ça
fait du bruit puisque des centaines de
bébés filles ont été nommés Véronique ça
a vraiment eu un impact et alors
deuxième conséquence c'est une
conséquence au niveau international
c'est-à-dire que dans le même temps les
États-Unis constatent qu'avec un engin
aussi rudimentaire que Véronique la
France est capable d'aller dans l'espace
et de faire des découvertes
exceptionnelles et c'est la réussite de
cette première campagne de tir qui lance
réellement les débuts des activités
spatiales en France la véronique devient
un nouvel emblème des prouesses
technologiques françaises
Véronique on aura la fierté de l'exposé
à différents endroits y compris au salon
du Bourget quelques mois plus tard en
juin 59 le général de Gaulle lui-même
viendra au stand où est exposé Véronique
pour admirer l'engin donc il y a une
prise de conscience nationale ou en tout
cas politique qui est en train de se
faire à ce moment-là de découvrir que
oui les savants français sont capables
de faire quelque chose même avec des
moyens rudimentaires
le centre militaire d'amaghir se met
désormais au service de la science et
devient la première base des activités
spatiales françaises
la base de hamguir au cœur du Sahara et
le centre d'expérimentation des engins
spéciaux français ou vient de se
dérouler une importante série de
lancement vers les plus hautes couches
de l'atmosphère terrestre
la base de lancement Véronique avait
rien du tout il y avait simplement deux
structures métalliques qui permettaient
d'accéder à la pointe deux ou trois
hangars et tout ça dans un espace
entouré par un fil de fer barbelé
Véronique sera installé ici parce que il
faut des installations spécifiques des
zones de stockage pour les liquides pour
remplir les réservoirs donc Véronique ne
pouvait pas être lancé n'importe où
n'importe comment d'autant plus que les
lancements des fusées véroniques étaient
parfois très aléatoire tout ne se
passait pas toujours comme prévu
on a eu surtout beaucoup de problèmes
avec les boulons pyrotechniques dès les
débuts de l'agence spatiale française le
CNES Marius Lefebvre a été responsable
de nombreux lancements de fusées et
notamment de Véronique il a construit sa
carrière auprès de différentes agences
spatiales en Europe le
QG Véronique n'est pas guidé elle est
posée sur une table elle a quatre
ailerons à l'extrémité de chaque aileron
il y a des bras et un extrémité des bras
il y a des câbles qui sont reliés à un
tambour qui est sous la table en
s'élevant la fusée déroule les câbles
qui maintiennent la fusée dans son axe
et tout ça c'est relié par des boulons
pyrotechniques et il suffit qu'un boulon
ne marche pas pour que un câble se
dégage pas ou pour un aileron ne soit
pas éjecté donc la trajectoire était
totalement changé et le lanceur pouvait
partir à l'horizontal
le lancement d'une fusée Véronique était
plus complexe que le lancement d'une
Ariane
quand on avait fait les plats et bien
c'était irréversible si on ne lançait
pas dans les quelques heures qui
suivaient il fallait vidanger et ramener
les lanceurs en métropole donc c'était
vraiment une responsabilité importante
d'autant plus que on en sait des charges
utiles pour des scientifiques qui
comptaient sur les résultats pour passer
une thèse ou essayer de se faire
connaître
les fusées que nous avons utilisées la
véronique en particulier sont des fusées
qui nous servaient en effet nous élever
au-dessus de l'atmosphère de la Terre
le parcours remarquable de Roger Maurice
bonnet la notamment conduit à diriger
pendant 18 ans au sein de l'Agence
spatiale européenne un programme majeur
pour les sciences spatiales et pour
l'observation de la Terre quand on lance
une fusée et qu'on sait qu'on est les
premiers à envoyer dans l'espace des
instruments que personne n'a construit
auparavant on sait qu'on va découvrir
quelque chose de nouveau et l'expérience
va très tôt apprendre à Roger Maurice
bonnet à ne pas se réjouir trop vite sa
première relation avec l'espace a lieu
en 1963 avec une Véronique il voulait
observer la couronne solaire ici encore
tout ne va pas se dérouler comme
souhaité
le lancement se présentait mal la météo
n'était pas bonne et les variations
devant étaient assez fortes et
finalement je décide de faire les pleins
et de lancer et on lance mais une fois
de plus un des boulons explosifs n'a pas
fonctionné et la fusée est partie de
travers dans le Grand airgue en zone
interdite
quand on m'a annoncé que ma fusée
c'était
désintégré à l'arrivée au sol je me suis
enfermé dans ma chambre et j'ai pleuré
pendant deux jours mais finalement on a
localisé la pointe et surtout on est
allé puis on a trouvé les boîtiers de
films donc j'ai de la chance
dans l'histoire des lancements de
Véronique on retiendra aussi la date du
22 février 1961 ce jour-là le premier
astronaute français est envoyé dans la
haute atmosphère il s'agit dura Hector
qui sera rapidement surnommé le
ratonaute son vol va durer 8 minutes
il a servi probablement plus que de
raison là la cause du spatial français à
l'époque parce que la presse s'est
emparée de l'événement et il a une
couverture journalistique extraordinaire
la cône de fusées Véronique et récupérer
dans le désert saharien après un bon
dans l'espace à 150 km d'altitude Hector
le racoba et des savants français était
du voyage il en revient très et dispo et
est aussitôt dirigé sur Paris où il
tient sa première conférence de presse
portant encore sur le crâne l'ampleur
était fixé pendant son vol les
électrodes de l'encéphalogramme
il fallait améliorer les connaissances
du comportement du vivant à de très
hautes effectif n'était pas d'envoyer
des astronautes l'objectif à long terme
en revanche c'était de faire comme les
Soviétiques notamment Sputnik 2 avec
Laïka c'est à dire le projet d'envoyer
un satellite avec des animaux à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
Véronique sera aussi celle qui le 9
avril 1968 va inaugurer à Kourou le tout
nouveau centre spatial français
son vol va durer 12 minutes avec une
altitude de culmination de 113 km
Véronique entre une nouvelle fois dans
l'histoire
la Guyane département d'outre-mer
français a été retenu parmi 15 autres
sites pour remplacer la base d'amagir à
l'indépendance de l'Algérie ses atouts
sont stratégiques pour les ambitions
futures de la France grâce à sa position
géographique proche de l'équateur les
fusées vont bénéficier de la vitesse de
rotation de la Terre
les lanceurs de satellites comme
aujourd'hui Ariane vont pouvoir emporter
des charges plus lourdes plus loin
l'idéal pour placer les futurs
satellites de télécommunication en
orbite géostationnaire à 36000 km de la
Terre
et avec son ouverture sur l'océan
Atlantique courroux permet aussi de
tirer vers le nord ce qui favorise
également les orbites polaires qui
permettent aux satellites d'observation
notamment de couvrir l'ensemble de la
surface du globe en une journée
les véroniques vont encore évoluer la
dernière la véronique 61m lancée pour la
première fois en 1966 était capable
d'emporter une charge de 100 kg à 325 km
d'altitude
en tout ce sont 5 versions
opérationnelles de Véronique qui ont été
mises en service depuis son premier tir
réussi en 1952 elle laisse dans les
mémoires le souvenir de très beaux
succès avec une moyenne de 8 tirs
réussie sur 10
[Musique]
la France a lancé sous son autorité pas
moins de 277 fusées sondes jusqu'en 1975
parmi lesquels plus de 75 Véronique
en effet d'autres engins ont été
développés en France durant cette
période
mais les passionnés reconnaîtront sans
doute que les engins en ont évocateur
bélier Centaure et Ridan et autres
tacites et Titus tirés depuis le monde
entier malgré toute leur qualité ne
peuvent détrôner la place de pionnière
qu'occupe à jamais les Véronique dans
l'histoire de la conquête spatiale
française
mais les fusées sondes n'étaient qu'une
composante des activités spatiales de la
France
c'est réellement avec le programme
pierre précieuse qu'elle va devenir la
troisième puissance spatiale
la France entreprend de retrouver non
pas un rang de grande puissance parce
qu'on se fait quand même pas d'illusions
mais un rang de puissance moyenne qui
compte sur la scène internationale l'une
des spécialités d'Isabelle sources
verger porte sur l'occupation de
l'espace autour de la Terre et la
comparaison des différentes politiques
spatiales tant dans leur dimension
technologique que politique
à l'époque finalement le grand domaine
je dirais d'un point de vue de
l'imagination des fous de du point de
vue de la symbolique c'est le domaine du
spatial alors que le général de Gaulle
retrouve le pouvoir en 1958 l'URSS et
les États-Unis sont devenus les deux
super puissances nucléaires
dans un contexte de guerre froide la
France entre dans la course aux
armements pour garantir sa sécurité en
toute autonomie
le succès des Véronique a certainement
influencé la décision générale de Gaulle
de faire l'effort de mettre au point une
force de frappe française mais la
technologie des véroniques n'était pas
suffisante au-delà de la haute
atmosphère c'est l'espace qu'il fallait
atteindre avec des fusées balistiques
seuls engins capables de frapper en
quelques minutes n'importe quel point de
la planète
persuader de cela le général de Gaulle
décide de financer un nouveau programme
le programme pierre précieuse pour
qualifier des engins de haute
technologie les premiers seront agathes
et topaze
et très vite Charles de Gaulle va
prendre conscience de la valeur ajoutée
de l'espace en terme d'indépendance dans
un premier temps grâce aux
communications à distance par satellite
je pense que le fait de vouloir avoir
une certaine autonomie en matière de
télécommunication spatiale
oblige la France à voir son autonomie en
matière de lanceur
et c'est ce que vont proposer les
ingénieurs militaires aux scientifiques
créer un lanceur de satellites à partir
des recherches effectuées sur la mise au
point des missiles balistiques du
programme pierre précieuse
nous sommes engagés dans dans nos
véhicules des cèpes avec ces véhicules
d'essai nous pouvons vous faire un
lanceur pour pas très cher pour un
investissement ridicule quelques
millions de francs anciens on pouvait se
retrouver avec des satellites dans
l'orbite
un accord est passé en 1962 entre le
ministère des armées et la toute jeune
agence spatiale française le CNES le
Centre national d'études spatiales pour
qu'un lanceur de satellites à vocation
civile soit développée
[Musique]
le programme militaire pierre précieuse
destinée à mettre au point la force de
frappe devient le programme diamant
il fallait un cheval de bataille il
fallait quelque chose qui soit capable
de conduire la France
dans une aventure spatiale une aventure
scientifique la fusée diamant sera
opérationnelle en 1965 elle est
l'aboutissement des recherches et du
développement mené sur les missiles
Agathe topaze émeraude rubis et saphir
pour ce qui est de la technique de
construction du lanceur diamant a il
s'agissait à l'époque de tout faire
d'apprendre surtout tout ça nécessitait
de tester les éléments séparément puis
ensuite on les a semblés comme un jeu de
Lego et ont testé l'ensemble
la construction entre fusée au départ
c'est un peu d'abidoule on a à chaque
fois appris de nos erreurs pour terminer
sur des processus de conception de
fabrication de qualifications de
procédures qui fait qu'à la fin on est
de plus en plus sûr et on a de moins en
moins d'échec diamant est un lanceur de
satellite à trois étages le premier
étage vient d'émeraude un étage à
propulsion liquide doté d'une tuyère
orientable qui arrachera du sol
l'ensemble de la fusée diamant
le deuxième étage a été mise au point
sur Topaz un étage à poudre qui prendra
le relais avec un système de tuyau
mobile le troisième étage vient de rubis
un propulseur à poudre cette fois encore
qui protège sous sa coiffe le satellite
a placé sur orbite
ces trois éléments associés composent
donc la fusée diamant capable d'envoyer
une charge de 130 kg à une altitude de
200 km
on essaie de démontrer que à côté des
États-Unis à côté de l'Union soviétique
et bien des puissances moyennes peuvent
aussi se lancer dans l'exploration
peuvent aussi être des puissances de
l'avenir et des puissances qui
maîtrisent une technologie qui a une
valeur symbolique et psychologique forte
et diamant va remplir un double objectif
pour la France
4 ans après le premier homme dans
l'espace mais aussi quatre ans avant le
premier homme sur la Lune la France
entre dans la cour des grands nous
sommes le 26 novembre 1965 en plein
désert algérien
la fusée diamant symbole de technologie
française décolle et parvient à placer
sur orbite à 1 baptisé très vite Astérix
le premier satellite français
Astérix fierté gauloise le petit Gaulois
qui arrive sur orbite avec ce succès la
France rejoint ainsi le club très fermé
des puissances spatiales autonomes
éprouvent dans le même temps sa capacité
à frapper sur n'importe quel point du
globe
les yeux des deux grandes puissances et
du monde entier se tournent avec
considération vers la France
diamant qui décolle c'était pas normal
c'était nouveau c'était pas normal on
cherche pas concurrence les Américains
c'était pas le but du jeu mais c'était
pas normal qu'un petit pays qui avait
pas grand chose sur ce plan là j'entends
arrive à faire un exploit digne des
grandes puissances on est quand même la
première puissance en dehors des
États-Unis l'Union soviétique
c'est-à-dire les deux superpuissances de
la guerre froide on est quand même les
premiers à mettre un petit peu le nez
dans l'atmosphère hors de l'atmosphère
et d'aller regarder ce qui s'y passe
placez un satellite en orbite c'est
relever un défi technologique immense
il faut être capable de compenser les
forces d'attraction terrestres pour
extirper du sol des engins de plusieurs
tonnes dans le seul but d'atteindre une
vitesse suffisante celle des 8 km par
seconde nécessaire pour placer une
charge en orbite autour de la Terre et
diamant à relever cette exploit avec son
satellite de 42 kg et de 55 cm de large
Astérix tout s'est passé en seulement 8
minutes et 15 secondes
au décollage diamant s'est arraché
lentement du sol le temps que ça
poussait de 28 tonnes s'établissent et
soulève les 18 tonnes de l'ensemble
la fusée prend peu à peu de la vitesse
en suivant la trajectoire prévue jusqu'à
épuisement du carburant du premier étage
à une minute et 31 secondes du lancement
diamant file déjà à 6000 km/h et à
atteint les 42 km d'altitude le deuxième
étage a pris le relais pour accélérer
encore jusqu'à 13500 km/h la procédure
de mise en orbite se poursuit diamant
est déjà à plus de 120 km du sol
le troisième et dernier étage délivre
toute sa puissance pour dépasser les
28000 km/h à plus de 500 km de la Terre
et peut ainsi libérer à cette vitesse le
satellite Astérix sur son orbite
une orbite qui ne devrait plus quitter
avant plusieurs dizaines d'années encore
mais malgré ce lancement à succès
Astérix a été victime dans la réalité
d'un léger incident sans pour autant
remettre en cause la mission de diamant
on a lancé Asterix il a jamais marché
tac au départ les cogne contre la contre
la coiffe cases les antennes pas un seul
bip bip rien mais je crois même savoir
que le Canard Enchaîné avait parlé de
satellite en carton et bout de ficelle
si nous avons su qu'il était en orbite
c'est premièrement parce que nous avions
nos radars et notre équipe de calcul
d'orbites qui a dit au gouvernement les
performances du lancement sont-elles
qu'on est en orbite puis après ça les
Américains ont dit qu'il avait vu et
qu'ils ont prévenu le lanceur est validé
le satellite montre que le lanceur
fonctionne mais dans le temps ça permet
aux militaires de de montrer vous voyez
que nous faisons notre évolution
balistique exactement comme le 4 octobre
57 l'avait fait les Soviétiques les
communautés spatiales qu'elles soient
américaines ou soviétique on conçoivent
du respect pour les Français parce qu'on
sait qu'ils ont travaillé avec
finalement peu de moyens qu'ils ont eu
des solutions techniques souvent
originales et assez astucieuses surtout
qu'il n'y a pas de concurr c'est vrai
que le lanceur diamant il va pas
remettre en cause la supériorité ni des
américains ni des Soviétiques mais après
tout ça fait un nouveau membre du club
et je crois qu'il est plutôt bien
accueilli avec diamant et le succès de
la mise en orbite d'Astérix la conquête
spatiale française prend une nouvelle
dimension et la France va confirmer la
maîtrise de sa technologie de lancement
avec un deuxième tir réussi
diamant va répéter l'exploit de placer
un autre satellite en orbite au début de
l'année 1966 non plus un satellite de
conception militaire comme Astérix
destiné seulement à valider les
compétences de la fusée mais un
satellite voué cette fois affaire de la
science
c'est la dimension scientifique qui
manquait à travers à la fois le lanceur
français et le satellite français il y
avait d'ailleurs un analyse du Figaro
qui avait dit que ce lancement donnait
tout son sens à la conquête spatiale
française la France est une puissance
spatiale parce que non seulement elle a
des lanceurs mais aussi elle a des
satellites mais aussi elle a une de
classe technique une industrie une
classe scientifique qui sont très forts
au total ce sont quatre fusées diamants
qui seront tirés avec succès jusqu'au
début de l'année 1967 depuis amagir une
version plus musclée vera le jour 3 ans
plus tard et sera tirer depuis Kourou
cette fois après diamant a place à
diamant B en 1970 qui ne conserve que le
deuxième étage de sa grande sœur
ses performances sont accrues diamant B
peut emporter une charge de 115 kg sur
une orbite située à 500 km de la Terre
une troisième et ultime version baptisée
BP4 sera même développé en 1975
ce que fait la France avec le programme
des fusées diamants est exceptionnel le
bilan de ses lanceurs est remarquable en
dix années d'exploitation 10 lancements
sur les 12 effectués ont été de réels
succès mais c'est bien pour ça le
diamant mérite d'être je dirais
réhabilité et remis en avant dans
l'histoire très modeste c'est vrai que
on peut pas comparer un diamant avec
avec Ariane puisque diamant je rappelle
c'est 80 100 kg à 500 km dans les
versions la version B Ariane on arrive à
1700 kg sur une orbite un peu plus
élevée que diamant donc on est sur une
technologie plus puissante avec Ariane
mais tout de même pour l'époque avec les
moyens dont la France disposait c'était
de belles performances que ce soit
Véronique ou que ce soit diamant on a
forcé le respect des deux grandes
puissances qui c'est bien pour ça qu'il
cherchait à coopérer avec nous
le programme diamant s'arrête
brutalement en 1975 l'heure est à la
collaboration européenne et la France
travaille depuis une quinzaine d'années
déjà sur un projet commun d'une fusée
bien plus grosse que diamant capable de
concurrencer les performances de
lancement des moyens Américains et
Soviétiques le général de Gaulle en
janvier 61 donne son accord contre la
vie de son entourage au Britannique pour
le développement du programme Europa
on est dans une époque où on baigne là
aussi dans le contexte de la
construction européenne pourquoi de
Gaulle qui n'a jamais voulu l'entrée de
la Grande-Bretagne en Europe a-t-il
voulu le lanceur Europa c'est parce
qu'il pensait que grâce à ce programme
ça aurait été un moyen de rapprocher du
continent les Britanniques là pour le
coup les Britanniques vont se retrouver
en porte-à-faux par rapport aux
Américains qui ne sont pas du tout
favorables à ce que l'Europe dispose
d'un gros lanceur c'est-à-dire dans
lanceur qui leur permettrait vraiment de
mettre autre chose que des satellites
scientifiques type Astérix mais et un
jour de participer à l'occupation et à
l'usage de l'espace pour des
applications commerciales l'idée du
programme Europa était d’assembler des
étages développer indépendamment par
plusieurs pays la France bien sûr
l'Angleterre ou encore l'Allemagne mais
les ratés s'enchaînent c'est un
programme qui a eu le mérite de montrer
que plusieurs pays européens pouvaient
avoir la volonté de travailler ensemble
mais en même temps
il a démontré que ça pouvait pas marcher
si chacun faisait un bout de son côté
sans qui est-ce qu'on appelle un maître
d'oeuvre ou un
intégrateur qui est responsable de
mettre de faire tout fonctionner
ensemble une version plus puissante
Europa 2 sera tenté mais toujours sans
succès le programme est jugé compliqué
et trop cher le repas est abandonné en
1973 malgré une proposition de la France
de développer une troisième version qui
ne séduit plus personne
la presse française s'en donne à cœur
joie et surnomme cette pauvre lancée
Europa le sous-marin puisqu'il avait une
fâcheuse tendance dès qu'il est collée
allait plutôt visiter le fond des océans
que aller voir exactement ce qui se
passait dans l'espace je crois qu'on a
beaucoup appris quand même tout le monde
a appris à faire au moins ce qu'il
fallait pas faire d'ailleurs quand vous
regardez bien tous les responsables qui
sont ensuite sur Ariane ont travaillé
sur Europa mais l'histoire du spatial se
construit aussi sur quelques coups du
sort la France souhaite à tout prix
pouvoir lancer des satellites
géostationnaires elle travaille avec
l'Allemagne sur son premier satellite de
télécommunication le satellite symphonie
faute de lanceur ce sont les Américains
qui acceptent de le placer en orbite
sous conditions
symphonie ne pourra pas être exploité à
titre commercial
une condition difficile à accepter mais
dont la France va tirer parti pour
convaincre ses partenaires européens
[Musique]
il aurait été écrit une lettre
émanant du département d'État américain
10 ans que finalement la NASA a renoncé
à lancer symphonie parce que symphonie
est un satellite commerciale et alors
cette lettre a sans doute existé c'est
pas là-dessus qu'il y a
l'instrumentalisation c'est sur le fait
que les Français se sont saisis de cette
lettre pour aller voir tous les pays
européens et au premier chef les
Allemands qui étaient directement
concernés en disant bah écoutez vous
voyez bien si on n'a pas un lanceur
indépendant chaque fois qu'on voudra
faire du vrai spatial des vrais services
de la vraie application les États-Unis
nous empêcheront de le faire et si on ne
veut pas que les États-Unis empêchent de
le faire on n'a pas d'autre solution que
de faire un lanceur ils se sont donc
deux ingénieurs du CNES qui proposent un
nouveau projet de lanceur moins gros
moins puissant moins ambitieux que repas
mais tout de même capable de placer en
orbite des satellites de l'ordre d'une
tonne ce sera le projet L3S pour lanceur
de substitution de 3e génération
L3S va devenir Ariane nouvelle arme de
séduction massive
mais Ariane sera pourtant complètement
remise en cause lors de l'élection en
1964 de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing à la
présidence de la République
en plein choc pétrolier la crise
économique ferrages et le président
souhaite faire des coupes budgétaires
il ne mesure pas à la différence de De
Gaulle les intérêts économiques et
stratégiques d'un lanceur européen ne
croyez pas du tout au
spatial et penser que c'était une
activité de prestige même titre que le
Concorde que le France
lorsque Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing est
arrivé au pouvoir il a dit à son
ministre de l'Industrie qui séchoir
monsieur d'Ornano Ariane cette sottise
avec moi ça tout de suite et il a fait
pendant six mois tout s'est arrêté
panique évidemment du côté du CNES et
des ingénieurs le programme est déjà
lancé les coopérations ont commencé il a
fallu convaincre le président pendant
quelques mois de dire mais voilà si la
France si on arrête de financer
qu'est-ce qu'on va aller dire à nos
partenaires européens on n'a pas
d'argent on arrête le programme il a
pris le dossier à vendre 10 ou le bras
et puis revenu lundi en disant j'ai
compris j'ai compris l'espace cet
européen et donc tout ce que fait la
France ou l'arrêté mais il a fallu en
même temps faire des coupes budgétaires
donc la première coupe ça a été diamant
tirant les leçons des échecs de repas le
CNES est alors désigné comme le seul
maître d'œuvre d'Ariane
les partenaires européens ne s'y
opposent pas pour deux simples et bonnes
raisons la France finance le programme
Ariane aux deux tiers et la qualité des
activités spatiales françaises n'est
plus à démontrer
Ariane est un programme majeur de
j'allais dire de l'Europe de la France
et la France qui a su motiver et
construire leur rope spatiale et donc
c'était quelque chose de d'extrêmement
important c'était donner la clé à
l'Europe
des activités spatiales rentables
utile importante pour les hommes que
nous sommes vivants en surface de la
Terre Ariane 1 va devenir à la fin des
années 70 pour la France et les pays
membres de l'Agence spatiale européenne
le moyen autonome d'accès à l'espace
capable d'emporter de très lourds
satellites et notamment de
télécommunications à des orbites qui
étaient jusqu'ici réservés aux deux
superpuissances spatiales
Ariane un nouveau lanceur qui va
pourtant être considéré par certains
comme dépassés face aux technologies
américaines mais l'histoire va démontrer
le contraire
côté américain on est en train de mettre
la dernière main à la navette spatiale
or ce que font les Européens c'est un
lanceur qui ressemble à ce que faisait
les Américains et les Soviétiques en
1957 et la presse de l'époque ne se
prive pas de souligner que nous on fait
un lanceur classique là où les
Américains font l'engin piloté du futur
là où les choses vont devenir
intéressantes c'est que l'engin piloté
du futur il s'avère un piètre moyen de
lancement et surtout quelque chose de
beaucoup trop coûteux et du coup Ariane
va pouvoir gagner cette place
extraordinaire sur le marché commercial
des lancements tout cela montrait que le
choix d'Ariane était le bon
le 24 décembre 1979 Ariane première du
nom décolle du Centre spatial guyanais 9
jours après la date initiale prévue
après deux reports de tir en raison de
l'eget dysfonctionnement mais
l'acharnement des ingénieurs à triompher
il fallait absolument satelliser avant
la fin de l'année il y avait bien à ce
psychologique historique c'est-à-dire
que si le satellisation réussie la
France est reconnue l'Europe est
reconnue une puissance spatiale dans les
années 70 si on satellise en 1980 la
France l'Europe serait devenue une
puissance spatiale dans les années 80
nous attendons toujours pour 15 minutes
et 12 secondes la séparation de la
charge utile c'est-à-dire de la capsule
technologique avec le troisième étage
voilà voilà c'est fait c'est fait nous
avons séparation capsule troisième étage
rempli son travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était important cariane réussisse
c'était notre réputation à nous Français
c'était pour l'Europe une étape
extrêmement importante et pour nous
Jean-Loup Chrétien et moi-même qui nous
trouvions avec tous ces gens-là par
hasard entre guillemets puisque en face
de sélection parti en ayant soviétique
communier participer avec eux à ce
lancement c'était quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et moi ça m'a beaucoup
marqué c'était mon premier pas dans
l'espace en quelque sorte on commençait
à avoir un lanceur de grandes dimensions
et à imaginer des hommes qui ont
développé un intérêt pour ses activités
c'était en pensant sournoisement à
trouver un siège là dessus un jour
la conquête spatiale jusqu'au début des
années 60 c'est une conquête spatiale
qui est d'abord scientifique qui est
d'abord politique et ensuite on entre
dans une autre démarche qui est un
espace utile un espace qui rapporte de
l'argent un espace commercial diamant ce
sont des statistiques qu'on lance il y a
pas d'enjeu économique alors qu'avec
Ariane ce sont des enjeux économiques
les contes des contrats sont déjà signés
avant même que le lanceur soit lancé
avec Ariane la conquête spatiale a
changé de nature
et la réussite économique d'Ariane est
garantie par une originalité française
encore une fois un opérateur de
transport spatial privé Arianespace est
créé quelques mois après le lancement de
la première fusée
son objectif commercialisé à ces deux
tirs pour assurer une production
industrielle suffisante et améliorer
toujours plus le lanceur de satellite
la France démontre son leadership
technologique et industriel une France
capable d'assumer la réalisation d'un
aussi gros programme dont elle est le
moteur au sein de l'Europe et les raté
des deuxièmes et 5e vol d'Ariane ne vont
faire que renforcer le travail des
équipes pour fiabiliser la fusée
il y a rien de fonctionne l'Europe
devient à son tour une puissance
spatiale une alternative au lanceur de
satellites russes et américains sans
pour autant inquiéter les deux grands
blocs je crois pas qu'on fasse jamais
peur
je pense qu'en revanche on devient
quelqu'un avec qui il faut compter c'est
un petit peu différent et ça veut dire
que pour les Américains et bien on va
structurer un petit peu différemment la
coopération avec les Européens et on va
les prendre un peu plus en considération
en termes par exemple de compétences
industrielles dans le développement des
nouveaux programmes sur le spaslap par
exemple qui est laboratoire qui va voler
à bord de la navette spatiale donc ça
crédibilise l'Europe du côté des
Soviétiques finalement on est plutôt
content qu'il y ait pas que les
Américains qu'elles se soucie pas trop
trop de ce qui se passe à l'extérieur
Ariane 1 sera celle qui le 22 février
1986 placera en orbite le satellite SPOT
le premier satellite français
d'observation de la Terre premier modèle
d'une longue série capable de dépointer
son instrument d'observation en dehors
de la trace au sol du satellite
et avec l'augmentation des masses des
satellites Ariane doit évoluer et
améliorer ses performances c'est toute
une famille de fusées qui va voir le
jour pour s'adapter aux besoins des
lancements avec notamment Ariane 4
nouvelle génération de lanceur modulable
avec ses propulseurs à poudre
des charges de 4700 kg peuvent être
placés sur orbite un argument commercial
décisif
et aujourd'hui Ariane 5
l'objectif d'Ariane 5 c'était 1 2
éventuellement de prévoir un lanceur
pour faire des voies habitées même s'il
y avait une volonté en France à travers
Jacques Chirac de soutenir le projet
Hermès d'une navette spatiale européenne
les partenaires européens soutiendront
pas donc le projet sera abandonné et
puis l'idée d'arène 5 c'est que comme
les satellites de télécommunication
entre autres prenaient de la masse
l'idée c'était plutôt que de voir un
satellite sur un lanceur et bien on va
faire un lanceur plus lourd qui va être
capable de lancer deux satellites de
télécommunication ce qui permettrait de
réduire les coûts ce qui me fascine le
plus et ce que je sais être le plus
difficile c'est la propulsion fusée
maîtriser la propulsion fusée je suis
pas un spécialiste des lanceurs mais
savoir que nos ingénieurs nos
scientifiques nos techniciens maîtrisent
la fabrication et le fonctionnement
d'une pompe à carburant comme on a dans
nos voitures mais qui fait rentrer du
liquide à moins de 100 degrés de quelque
part et c'est plus de 1000 degrés dans
la chambre de combustion à la sortie
ça c'est la maîtrise par la France de la
propulsion des cryogénique à oxygène
hydrogène liquide qui est très propre
puisque les gaz de combustion c'est de
la vapeur d'eau on peut dire avec Ariane
5 on suit vraiment à égalité et parfois
même mieux avec ce que sont capables de
faire les autres grandes puissances
spatiales qui ont maîtrisé la technique
des fusées longtemps avant la domination
d'Ariane dans les lancements civils
s'est confirmé bénéficiant d'un contexte
de drame avec l'échec de la navette
américaine
Ariane fleuront d'un spatial désormais
européen
Dorian 1 à Ariane 5 ce nom résonne
aujourd'hui plus que jamais comme un
modèle de fiabilité et d'excellence
depuis 1979 plus de 220 lancements de
fusées de la famille Ariane ont permis
la mise en orbite de près de 400
satellites
avec Ariane 5 ce sont près de 70
lancements consécutifs sans échec
un taux de réussite remarquable et les
rares incidents de parcours qu'elle a pu
connaître n'ont fait que renforcer le
programme
Ariane s'impose à travers le monde comme
l'accès privilégié d'un espace qui
s'industrialise
la France a écrit l'histoire elle a
réussi à fédérer ses voisins européens
et à créer une nouvelle puissance
spatiale
la France n'aurait pas pu être une
puissance spatiale à elle toute seule et
c'est pour ça que je pense que dès le
début tout le monde était convaincu que
si véritablement il devait y avoir une
présence tiers dans l'espace à côté de
celle des Américains et des Russes ça ne
pouvait être qu'une puissance européenne
et certainement pas un pays européen
tout seul avec Ariane le Centre spatial
guyanais c'est considérablement
développé
véritable port spatiale de l'Europe la
France accueille désormais sur cette
terre de nouvelles fusées Vega Soyouz et
enrichit ainsi son offre de lancement de
satellite
et demain un nouveau projet d'Ariane est
en route
ce camion de l'espace devra relever le
défi de rester aussi fiable que ses
aînés
l'histoire spatiale française est
d'abord écrite avec le développement de
ses fusées
de Véronique Ariane la France est le
troisième pays à cette illustrée dans
une course que le monde pensait réserver
aux deux super puissances américaine et
soviétique
avec diamant les regards ont convergé
vers la France devenu en 1965 la
troisième puissance spatiale
une puissance scientifique technique
capable de concrétiser de grands projets
avec finalement peu de moyens
[Musique]
avec ses fusées c'est l'espace qui est
devenu accessible au satellite
les engins spatiaux français ne cessent
désormais de nous accompagner au rythme
de l'évolution de nos modes de vie et
nous permettent aussi d'en découvrir
toujours plus sur nos origines
et la coopération internationale qui
s'est depuis développée a déjà permis à
9 français d'embarquer à bord de fusée
russe et américaine pour des missions
spatiales en orbite à quelques centaines
de kilomètres de la Terre
le dixième est en chemin
histoire de la conquête de l'espace
continue
[Musique]